a top children's health officials for
the EPA who was suddenly put on
administrative leave is now speaking out
only on CBS this morning dr. Ruth Etzel
is her name she was sidelined back in
September the agency says it was over
allegations about her leadership but did
not provide details and her Werner spoke
to dr. Etzel about what she says
happened and why she's now worried about
the direction of the EPA Anna good
morning good morning Gail the reaction
from health and environmental experts
who know dr. Etzel to her being put on
leave shocked stunned and worried about
whether the EPA truly wants to have
regulations that protect children our
message is no longer welcome the message
that children are not little adults and
they need special protections is not
welcome making sure children are
protected from environmental toxins has
been dr. Ruth Etzel job at the EPA
she's the agency's top pediatric expert
the author of textbooks and policy
handbooks on children's environmental
health so basically your job was to go
to EPA and say hey this regulation that
you're considering you need to know how
that impacts children exactly I often
think of the office of children's health
as the conscience of EPA because you
know we're kind of nagging at them is
this okay for children are you sure this
is okay for children but from the
beginning of the Trump administration
dr. Etzel says it seemed those above her
no longer wanted her advice her monthly
meetings to advise the EPA Administrator
were abruptly halted so you had no
one-on-one meetings with Scott Pruitt
and you had no one-on-one meetings with
Andrew wheeler no not one not one and
she says a national strategy to remove
lead from children's environments
launched after the Flint Michigan water
crisis stalled with one official brought
in by the new administration telling her
that anything involving new regulations
wouldn't fly my sense is that the
government has absolutely no intention
of taking any actions towards seriously
changing let in children's environments
and what does that mean for the kids it
basically means that our kids will
continue to be poisoned it basically
means that kids are disposable they
don't matter through it all she says she
kept pushing until about three weeks ago
when an official came into her office my
boss who's the deputy chief of staff
walked in and handed me a piece of paper
and said I'm putting you on
administrative leave and I almost fell
off on my chair I said what's this about
and she wouldn't say didn't know any
idea what was happening or why I was
happening none whatsoever
did you have any warning no nothing
nothing in a letter to EPA over 120
environmental and health organizations
expressed their great concern saying by
placing dr. Etzel on leave the EPA has
sent a signal that children's health is
not a priority for the agency so at a
meeting last week we approached EPA
officials acting deputy chief of staff
Helen a wooden Aguilar as the person dr.
Etzel says came into her office that day
why was she not told the reasons why she
was put on leave
unfortunately I can't comment on that he
also asked her boss Chief of Operations
Henry Darwin the man right under
Administrator Andrew wheeler it's really
inappropriate for me to talk about any
personnel related issue okay but why is
dr. Etzel on administrative leave like I
just said it's very inappropriate for me
to talk about personnel issues but
should she have been told why she was
put on administrative leave you want me
to say it again I really can't comment
on personnel related issues as for dr.
Etzel after three weeks on paid leave
she says it's time to speak out this is
totally wrong and the only people that I
really report to our mothers and fathers
and communities in the United States and
if they won't let me tell about how
children are being poisoned I'll just
tell the mothers and fathers directly so
I have that right whether or not
EPA wants me on their staff what if they
come up later and say well you did these
things wrong if I did then I'll say okay
if I did it then I'll say I didn't
you know but I don't know what the
allegation is so it's very hard to it's
very hard to know but basically I'm a
straight shooter
I'm transparent so if I make a mistake I
own it
well dr. Etzel made clear to us she's
speaking as a pediatrician not an EPA
official the EPA referred us to a
statement from chief of staff Ryan
Jackson who said that dr. Etzel was
placed on leave to give the agency the
opportunity to review allegations about
the directors leadership of the office
but dr. Etzel tells us she has never
been made aware of any allegations the
EPA insists it's committed to protecting
children and maintains that dr. excells
removal won't affect its work well once
we've heard dr. ensel's charges we
cannot now unhear them and as a parent I
would be very concerned about what's
going on over there yeah never doubt
that one person can make it mr. Bryton
or bring to light what is happening and
she is clearly in my view looking out
for the health and welfare of children
as she said and she says if she's wrong
she will own that too but she's worked
at a leaking of public health for 30
years including at the World Health
Organization as professor thank you no
thank you I'm sure she'll be hearing
from a lot of parents after that yeah 20
people on that letter and her former
bosses